when THQ started looking like it wasn't
going to survive I think a lot of us a
lot of us in studio were we're wondering
what our future was going to be we were
wondering what the future of our
franchises were going to be stone war
it's company heroes easier these are
deeply loved products and to see that
stopped happening was I think for a lot
of us what's a little bit heartbreaking
game development is a tricky balancing
act for small studios with big ideas
there is a need to weigh up creative
ambition with business realities for
these burgeoning Studios overextension
can often sink the ship before its sales
even catch wind Canadian studio relic
entertainment is an example of a small
scrapping studio that through smart
decisions and a focus vision has become
an industry leading developer over the
course of its twenty-year history has
grown into one of the biggest players in
the strategies onra pioneering gameplay
innovation through titles such as
Company of Heroes and dawn of war but
that journey has been far from smooth
while relic has established itself as an
authority voice within the strategy
genre many of its successes have been
achieved while balanced on a Razors Edge
with canceled projects buyouts and
bankruptcies threatening to cut extreme
short and as with many studios owned by
a major publisher relic has been forced
out of its comfort zone numerous times
often with unfavorable outcomes but for
its developers these failures have been
as formative to the studio as its
successes for this in-depth look at the
studio's storied past we flew out to
Vancouver to reflect on the studio's
twenty-year legacy its darkest hours and
how it has against all odds helped
change the face of strategy
[Music]
welcome to Vancouver British Columbia
home to 2.1 million people 3 ski
mountains and 44% of the Canadian games
industry this is where relic
entertainment has always called home
from its humble beginnings as a two-man
operation above a bar to the hundred and
ninety strong team of developers at the
forefront of the strategy genre today
when Alice Garden and Luke Maloney
founded relic their vision was to become
the world's best realtime strategy
studio a lofty ambition when the genre
was dominated by titans such as Age of
Empires command & Conquer Total
Annihilation and Warcraft
[Music]
but Relic quickly made its mark with
homeworld it was the first RTS to
completely utilize 3d space and the
first that had persistency through
missions homeworld is a seminal game
that established many of the fundamental
principles of the RTS games of today
still a dear - I don't think relic had a
roadmap I think it was more immediate
and and visceral it started with the
sort of tech demo of homeworld and and
what Alex Garden called the spaghetti
ball you know a bunch of strike craft
spinning around like a capital ship and
the realization that it would be first
out the gate with that sort of
technology you know you gotta remember
back in late 90s
everything was sprites it was pretty
groundbreaking and we saw the the
opportunity for a relic to be placed on
the map I went at Alex's office he had
the mothership sitting on the screen and
and then all of a sudden you see sort of
turned the camera and I just instantly
got goosebumps it just stood out so
dramatically compared to to the sort of
the peers at the time that became I
think more challenging later on first
time around you're just like I don't
know you just kind of do your thing and
it works or doesn't you know you don't
know afterwards it gets a little scarier
after the success of homeworld propelled
relic into the spotlight it followed up
its sci-fi classic with impossible
creatures which was a somewhat more
eccentric take on the RTS games
publisher THQ harvest saw promise in the
chances relic were taking with the genre
and move to acquire them in 2004 with
the backing of THQ relic was given the
opportunity to realize its ambitions on
a much grander scale dawn of will allow
the studio to continue innovating but
also leveraged Warhammer 40,000 an IP
there could be a springboard for its
very own blockbuster franchise but the
stability of THQ came with its own risks
and questions chief among them whether
or not the influence of major
corporation could change the studio's
identity perhaps compromising what makes
relic relic I think anytime you get you
get acquired you there's a sense of what
will make it through you know it will
the the character the studio survive are
they going to come in and change things
you know I I can recall the purchase
being oh we're bought now Oh
okay cool oh good
THQ was a bit of a surprise in the day
all of a sudden our finance guy who
usually is strict on everything that
would be purchased be like I get a new
monitor really like I can have two so I
think we saw some some freedom from that
working with THQ being being under their
umbrella we would have been able to have
the freedom and the time and the space
to develop a game like company Heroes
Company of Heroes is the game that relic
is best known for a guarded widespread
critical acclaim for its nuanced
depiction of war and the cost of
sacrifice which explored through
narrative and gameplay it remains one of
the studio's highest-rated games but
development was plagued with uncertainty
you know the original vision started
with kind of this grandiose paragraph of
kind of history and heroism you know
then it sort of got boiled down over
time to kind of that real real soldiers
real battlefields real war just to
capture the tone and the movement and
the language and the kind of all the
kinetic violence of you know what we'd
seen in the movies and documentaries the
the whole the whole sort of mandate was
to make real the emotional impact of
Band of Brothers and saving program they
wanted to strip away all the sort of
symbolic abstractions that come along
with a strategy game and sort of
collapse them into something that was it
was more realistic and and based on sort
of serving that fidelity it took a long
time before it started to feel like a
game like a like an experience like just
to get a single infantryman running
around shooting everything felt crappy
they didn't there's no pace or rhythm or
anything to any of the of the combat and
then we had some some pretty hard
deadlines we were showing the game I
think to PC gamer
it wasn't until then that things started
to come together and you're like oh okay
now now we see now we see what this game
is meant to be I think that it it pushed
RTS into areas that people didn't think
it could could live you know it looked
like a shooter brought to life you know
from a drone cam and I think that still
stands out
[Music]
by 2006 Relic had cemented its status as
a major player in the RTS genre at this
point it's back catalogue included
homeworld impossible creatures Dawn of
War and the highest-rated strategy game
of all time Company of Heroes relic had
not only met its lofty goal of becoming
one of the best RTS studios in the world
it actually turned the whole genre on
its head in the process but at the very
peak of its success relic began to
experience setbacks THQ wanted to
diversify the studio's output it
mandated an expansion into the console
shooter market with the outfit and chase
the MMO trend with a Company of Heroes
online both titles pulled relic out of
its comfort zone and onto unfamiliar
ground third-person action game the
outfit was radek's first for right
outside strategy and it's an experience
was evident I think there was this idea
that we had all these sort of high-res
assets from CoH and on on the executive
level it was like an idea that we could
take those and put into an Xbox game
there were I think there was there was a
desire to to broaden the kind of
business end of things maybe make the
studio a little more accessible to a
bigger audience which usually is you
know his approach to go after more money
given our sort of track record I think
that was kind of one of the first sort
of like blemishes on that for me and
personally it was probably a bridge too
far I think like like we could have got
there but more incrementally it always
struck me as a project that wasn't
developed from from the ground up the
feeling of what way can we innovate on a
game idea and develop a project out of
it it always felt a bit top-down and
most setbacks followed after a lukewarm
reception Company of Heroes online was
cancelled one of the major stumbling
blocks for the title was a lack of
infrastructure within THQ the publisher
wanted an MMO but didn't have the
ability to support one their next
release saw them jump back into the
world of third-person action albeit with
the Warhammer 40,000 IP that they were
already familiar with Space Marine I
think was probably in development for
I'm going to say three years maybe
before it even became Space Marine
it started as something very different a
different IP different kind of game and
talk about setbacks a number of
different kinds of setbacks and the team
kept trying to find a way through this
sort of maze of development and then we
had a license that that THQ had for a
while as soon as that license touched
down one of the the higher up designer
is on the project he took some dawn of
war assets and he dropped the camera and
he hooked up sis quick like a control
scheme to it and everybody gathered I
was like holy moly once we saw like the
raw potential of it we all dough VIN on
that and it was not smooth but because
of the clarity of the initial intent I
think that that sort of was the thread
that pulled the project long yeah but
meanwhile like you know that that
cartoon with the dog in the in the in
the room and and and and he's in the
thought bubbles everything's fine and
the room is like on fire like like in
some ways like with with what was going
on with THQ in retrospect we felt like
that dog because like we were trying to
do the right thing in the midst of like
just like yeah stuff stuff in this case
means the ongoing financial difficulties
THQ are facing the effects of which was
starting to trickle down onto the
developers and studios under its
umbrella the threat of closure was a
constant shadow looming over every
member of the relic team a fact that was
made all the more real when it came to
the cancellation of planned future
projects including the continuation of
the Space Marine series as a huge fan of
the game hearing the relic had a vision
for more Space Marine titles but weren't
able to deliver on them broke my heart
into 40,000 pieces well I mean when we
found out we weren't going to be able to
do those sequels that was a tough day in
the studio you know I don't think any
development team who you know enjoys
those moments when the future we had
mapped out just didn't come to pass
their dreams of what if that's still
linger every once in a while in
conversations that you know Space Marine
team a number of people have moved on to
two other companies they were brought in
for their sort of console and plot
form expertise I I think there was some
some great things in Space Marine Space
Marine two would have been unbelievable
I think just what we had learned on
original what are you gonna do
in December 2012 after a string of
highly publicized failures including the
misjudge you draw tablet THQ was forced
to declare bankruptcy for the employees
many of whom had been at relic for most
of their careers the studio the brands
and their relationships that they'd
built over the past 15 years all now
hung in the balance there's a lot of
anxiety there's a lot of fear I think
when THQ started looking like it wasn't
kind of survive a lot of since studio
were we're wondering what our future was
going to be we were wondering what the
future of our franchises were going to
be you know I know I dusted off my CV at
the time thankfully I didn't make a move
on that but you know I had a family to
take care of personally speaking and and
I was trying to see what the what the
well you know what the parachute might
look like you worried that all that work
is gonna get lost and there's gonna be
nothing for the future stone war its
Company of Heroes these are these are
deeply loved products and to see that
stopped happening was I think for a lot
of us was just a little bit
heartbreaking it was December of 2012 I
believe and we were in the midst of
trying to finish Company of Heroes 2 and
all of a sudden were like ok so we're
trying to have this game done in a
couple months and all of a sudden we may
not have a parent company to ship it you
know I'm kind of putting my head down to
feel like well at least finish this
because if there's no finished game no
one wants to buy us we were well
underway on on company heroes to him it
was it was sort of several months from
from shipping at that point so we had a
we had something to show we had
something of value to demonstrate and it
sounds a bit morbid but you have we had
you know half a dozen major publishers
kind of coming through the studio and
kicking the tires and checking the pulse
of the of the team and you know it felt
like we were going to
land somewhere in January 2013 an
auction of th hues various assets was
approved as studios and IPS were
dissected and put up for auction
the devs back in Vancouver just had to
sit back and wait for the word on the
fate of relic at this time disillusion
became a very real possibility I think
at the time we weren't sure if we were
going to be split up or you know THQ was
looking at a venture capital firm to
kind of keep the whole thing together
and going and I guess the judge made a
pretty pivotal decision that THQ was
worth more torn apart it was an auction
for online a stream of the auction of
thos assets and we were all refreshing
and with bated breath trying to see who
would go where people from the studio
back east that are sending emails
reporting in like these people are
bidding and this kind of thing is
happening we were in a bit of a bidding
war and Sega came up and I think ZeniMax
and a couple of other studios you know
came up and Sega like wow okay that's
really interesting how does that you
know Google and we're trying to figure
out what the strategy was because they
had creative assembly and they had
sports interactive and it's like let's
another PC strategy and they got PC
strategy and how is this working a
couple days after the purchase the
president of Sega of Japan came to the
office and the thing I remember him
saying is you guys make great strategy
games we bought you because you make
great strategy games keep making great
strategy games it was an amazing feeling
to suddenly have oh you know Sega wanted
us and they paid a lot of money for us
and to have that kind of external
validation to have somebody else
recognize that and see the value in it
and understand the value and it was was
hugely gratifying and that was there was
a really nice feeling
[Music]
relevant for the panic of an uncertain
future to the glimmer of hope in the
shape of a crowded corporate auction and
then finally for the saving grace of
their Sega acquisition so against the
odds perhaps relic are still around
today and are celebrating their 20th
anniversary from what started as the
plucky underdog taking on a genre giants
it has managed to weather multiple
storms and come out the other end with
its vision for the strategy genre as
clear as ever I feel like sometimes if I
was a picture relic as a person who'd be
like neo in the matrix and like just the
bullets flying at them and he's like and
I don't know if it's just sheer luck I
don't know if it's like tenacity we see
what we want to build and then we build
it it turns out people like that and so
we keep doing that you know that's gonna
be what drives the successful studio um
what is the magic eye
stubborn determinism you know um I think
we've kept we've kept strategy in you
know in view but I think collectively
the franchises we've done have you know
they've stood the test of time they've
they've had great critical acclaim
they've been interesting and innovative
and are uniquely Relic I think all of
them even even as different as some of
them are they're uniquely Relic thank
you so much for watching this video all
about the history of relic now I've been
playing relic games since I was a kid I
still playing them with an adult so it's
a real honor to talk to the guys at
relic share their story and share their
legacy with you if you want to see more
than you can watch the making of Dawn of
War three video that we put up last week
and make sure you leave your thoughts in
the comment section down below I'm going
to be in there over the next few days
talking to you guys hearing your
thoughts filling in any spaces that I
can so make sure you get in the comments
section and if you enjoyed this video
make sure you hit the like button
subscribe and I'll see you next time
also I'm sorry that space ring too is
happening
[Music]
huh